well brian it's certainly been a tough
year with a lot of people experiencing
loss
and while it's hard on everyone kids can
really have a hard time
processing grief but here in the valley
there's a program designed to help
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us with more on
camp cope madison yes denise this
program began
its new multi-week session last week and
i got the opportunity to speak to the
founder of the organization
along with a family who has benefited
greatly from these services
we started camp cope after i lost my son
and jonathan lost his brother
and it has been so wonderful because
just
him being able to talk to other people
around his age going through
some of the same feelings he's going
through not being afraid to talk about
your feelings is a big deal for adults
let alone kids but camp cope helps with
that
by offering programs that specialize in
helping children manage their feelings
while dealing with loss and while many
families endure the loss of a loved one
loss doesn't always mean death as
founder kelly thomas boyers explains
deportation incarceration deployment
divorce that child has experienced a
disruption in that family unit
and need some support and needs to
recognize that they're not
the only one that they can connect to
others that have similar feelings
because of the pandemic all of their
sessions for the past year have been
virtual
and the need has been greater than ever
families like the johnsons are thankful
for the help that adams plays and camp
cope
has provided to them i think it's really
helped him to be able to
identify his feelings and not be so
afraid to talk about him all the staff
there are really nice and understanding
and no one ever speaks over you so if
you're trying to talk about something
you can talk about it
and camp cope is affiliated with adam's
place a grief center for children and
families
organizers work closely with ccsd so you
can reach out to them and reach out to a
school counselor
to get you and your child started
reporting in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now yeah they really do
great work thanks madison